there are three possibilities for
headmaster or headmistress in hogwarts
legacy first up there's upraxia mole she
was the headmistress of hogwarts school
of witchcraft and wizardry in 1876 the
year in which she played a significant
role in a pretty hilarious situation
involving peeves the poltergeist we know
this thanks to one of jk rowling's
pottermore writings from august of 2015.
she writes though many students and even
teachers have a somewhat perverse
fondness for peeves he undoubtedly adds
a certain zest to school life he is
incurably disruptive and it generally
falls to the caretaker of the day to
clean up his many deliberate messes
vases smashed potions upended bookcases
toppled and so on later in the article
we learned there have been a few
attempts to actually remove peeves from
the castle all of which resulted in
failure by the way no surprise to potter
fans considering his prominence in the
series although you wouldn't know that
if you've only seen the movies it turns
out one of those aforementioned attempts
to kick peeves out of hogwarts happened
in the year 1876 when mole was
headmistress rancorous was the caretaker
during those days and he'd designed an
elaborate trap for peeves the trap
consisted of a collection of weapons
intended to bait peeves along with a
large enchanted bell jar which he
intended to drop over the poltergeist
once he was in place rowling writes not
only did peeves break easily through the
giant bell jar showering an entire
corridor with broken glass he also
escaped the trap armed with several
cutlasses crossbows a blunderbuss and a
miniature cannon the castle was
evacuated while peeves amused himself by
firing randomly out of the windows and
threatening all and sundry with death
now this actually led to a three-day
standoff between peeves and the hogwarts
professors headmistress mole ultimately
reached a contractual agreement with
peeves to end the standoff this
agreement granted peeves certain
privileges including a weekly swim in
the boys toilets on the ground floor
that is first refusal on stale bread
from the kitchen for throwing purposes
in addition to a custom-made hat to be
designed by madame bonnibal of paris
carp ended up taking an early retirement
for health reasons and no other attempts
have been made since to remove peas from
the castle with hogwarts legacy likely
starting in 1891 we won't be witnesses
to this infamous standoff with peeves
but mole could very well still be the
headmistress if not mole the next
possibility would be brutus scrimjor
when it comes to scrimjor some may argue
that it's never actually been confirmed
that he was a hogwarts headmaster if you
consult the harry potter lexicon which
has long been a trusted source for
potter fans you'll find no mention of
him as headmaster on the hp wiki however
it's said that he served as headmaster
of hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry thanks to two sources the harry
potter for connect video game and the
making of harry potter a movie behind
the scenes walking tour of the wb studio
in london in both cases scrimjor appears
as a portrait in the headmaster's office
now personally i'm not convinced that
scrim jor was ever truly considered a
hogwarts headmaster by jk rowling this
could very well have been a prop mix-up
and just something they had positioned
in the headmaster's office for the
studio tour he also appeared in a
portrait in the prisoner of azkaban film
as well as the video games for prisoner
of azkaban order of the phoenix and half
blood prince although none of those were
in the headmaster's office to be fair
the quest of circadogen a feature on
disc two of the prisoner of azkaban dvd
confirms he was definitely at least a
professor at hogwarts it's also very
possible he was related to rufus
scrimgeour but this isn't confirmed as
canon what is confirmed is that he wrote
a guide for quidditch players
specifically beaters known as the
beater's bible he also wrote a review
for the book quidditch through the ages
calling it the definitive work on the
origins and history of quidditch and
also adding that he highly recommended
it our third and final possibility for
headmaster is certainly the most
recognizable name of the three and it's
none other than phineas nigellus black
or maybe it's nigelus either way i know
you guys will all let me know in the
comments below the correct way to
pronounce it black of course played a
fairly important role in the original
harry potter series well at least his
portrait did anyway often passing
important messages to dumbledore he had
a second portrait in number 12 grimald
place which he could travel to and from
along with his hogwarts portrait often
snide and sarcastic it's no surprise his
great-great-grandson sirius black would
describe him as the least popular
headmaster in the history of the school
he did attend hogwarts as a student and
was sorted into slytherin later in his
adult life he would return to hogwarts
first as a teacher before going on to
serve as headmaster it's believed that
he hated his job as a teacher which he
found tedious and thought of his
students as self-obsessed while he
didn't bar muggleborns from attending
hogwarts he certainly carried his family
grudge against muggleborn wizards even
referring to them as mudbloods in the
harry potter series again that's through
his portrait despite his beliefs on the
importance of blood purity black's
portrait did not support the death
eaters and he was pleased when voldemort
was defeated if you're curious about my
guess i think this professor right here
is phineas black he bears an uncanny
resemblance to sirius black also phineas
was born in 1847 which would put him
right around the age of 44 in 1891 when
hogwarts legacy takes place i think this
guy looks definitely like he could be 44
years old the question then becomes is
he just a teacher or is he actually the
headmaster as well of course i want to
know what you all think who will be the
headmaster in hogwarts legacy mole scrim
draw or black or will they surprise us
all and take some creative liberty and
make it none of those three comment
below to let me know as always thank you
all so much for watching i'll talk to
you again soon